foreign
let's go to Gray in Tampa Florida what's
up gray
how's it going Dr Don deloney I'm John
but good man how are you
that's what I meant very cool uh what's
up dude how are you things I was gonna
say um was you you uh you have
permission to call me on my cow pies so
you already started with that we're off
to a good start excellent hey uh real
quick you're there in Florida uh y'all
make out okay y'all doing okay
after the hurricane I live I live about
an hour north of Tampa so we were okay
but uh with my job I'm an electrician
I've been down in in the thick of it all
week and it's pretty pretty
heartbreaking yeah well thank you for
being one of the linemen out there
working
um I know you guys are working around
the clock to get power restored to that
community so thanks for your for your
service my brother
yeah I'm not a lineman but I do all the
commercial stuff so as they bring in
power I'm there to uh uh to help get it
going awesome awesome make sure
everybody's safe inside you well thank
you so much man all right what's up how
can I help
okay
um
you're gonna have to kind of bear with
me through uh
through this
um but first i'm gonna give you
permission to speak into my life
um so
awesome I have I have a daughter
um who's five years old
and she lives in Alabama with her mom
and stepdad
okay last year
my daughter's mother reached out to me
and asked if her
husband could adopt my daughter
um having me sign over asking if I would
be willing to sign over my parental
rights
and uh
allow him to adopt
and it came at a really rough time
um like I got that that text
um yes she sent it in a text so that's a
whole another story but uh she sent in a
text as I was pulling back in the
driveway from my little brother's
funeral
okay so I I didn't have time to co
couldn't cope with those two things at
once and now it's been some time and uh
I don't know how to walk forward on this
I have been out of my daughter's life
um
for most most of her life after
um
the the courts and uh
I don't know the proper term here so
forgive me but after
fraternity was established right before
my daughter turned two
um I did have a relationship with my
daughter we would video chat pretty
consistently
um
I would talk to my daughter's mom on the
phone probably three or four days a week
and video chat with my daughter a
minimum of two days a week for about a
year
and then my daughter's mom thought it
would be best for her to only have one
dad in her life and that wasn't me
so she hasn't wanted me a part of my
daughter's life for the past
about two two years and uh
I haven't gone to a court system to try
to fight and that's kind of what I'm
calling about is
I don't know if it's
right to to to fight and go through the
Battle of custody
um
when I've seen how my daughter's mom
reacts to her
her son's
father my daughter has an older brother
um the same mom and uh they they dealt
with that and
even though the courts did get involved
it still wasn't a good situation for
nearly anybody
um and I don't know the ramifications of
of that on a kid my parents were
divorced and lived in different states
for a little while
um
but I also
grew up in the home with my mom and dad
until about
Middle School
so it was a bit of a different situation
there Winston when's the last time
you've seen your baby girl
um four years ago why
one is
I
haven't been in the area and I haven't
been why why
this is a particularly hard call for me
because I got a six-year-old little girl
uh and I I know that's why I gave you
permission to speak in my life and I
knew it was going to be hard well I I I
I I so yeah I'm just going to be direct
with you
um
I've I flew my family out to be with me
this weekend while I was doing an event
in Los Angeles and they came and we ran
around town and it was fun
and then they flew out a day early
because I had an event to do
I I almost woke my daughter up last
night when I got home
and it was 24 hours
I don't breathe well when she's not
around
the idea of going four years
intentionally
like bro I'd be mowing yards in Alabama
dude I don't know what I don't know I I
can't wrap my head around it
psychologically
so why haven't you seen your daughter in
four years
I don't have a good answer for that um
every every time I have
attempted it has been shut down
um
with
um you're you're not your
your daughter's dad anymore and hey hold
on we don't want her to know about you
well she's gonna know about you so
that's I I know I know that's the case
but but no they are right you haven't
been her dad
correct that's fair you fathered this
kid but you have not been her dad
correct
um
going all the way back to the beginning
it's a lane that she sent this into a
text and you might be the kind of guy
that has to get it in a text because
she's not safe to call you on the phone
or you're gonna act like an idiot or
what who knows man or she's gonna get
mad who knows
um
but if that's what you're if that's how
she felt safest to contact you that's I
mean that's not how I would have done it
but I don't have a relationship with you
and I don't know how you are about
things
um
like I'll be
video chat is not a relationship
correct
um you basically were a television show
for your daughter
with an interactive character
a relationship is showing up and
physical touch and eyesight and letting
her see a part of herself in you because
a part of her is in you
that's a relationship so you
chit-chatted on a on a computer right
but that's not relationship
um
like I can be I'll be honest with you
this sounds more about ego than it does
about your daughter
this sounds more like you're struggling
with the fact that you're gonna put a
period at the end of a sentence and let
another man raise your daughter
and if that's the case you need to get
over yourself and let the man who
stepped up to be in her life be fully in
her life
and that's that's what it's about
um so I'm I'm married with a a son
um and we obviously live in Florida
um and
um my wife and I have had a handful of
conversations about this
and
um
the the option is let her her new
husband obviously be her her dad or my
wife and I go all in move to Alabama and
do whatever we can to
to find a way to be a part of my
daughter's life
and I don't know what either one of
those look like and I'm pretty
pretty scared of both options honestly
yeah man you've backed yourself into
quite the corner
um
actually you know what you haven't
you let your daughter go a long long
time ago
um you're trying to reinsert yourself
into her life
um I can imagine your current wife does
she have a hard time with this
yes
I can't imagine being married to
somebody who would let one of their kids
just just roll off
like I would think less of the my
romantic partner does that make sense
yeah
um a little bit more more context
um like I said when the courts establish
paternity that was just before my
daughter turned two
Fighters
um well my daughter's mom and I split up
um
before even the first ultrasound so we
weren't even sure
um
you know it at the time I we weren't
sure if I was even the father but why'd
you wait two years for a paternity test
why don't you get a paternity test the
second that baby was born
because I was terrified just like I am
today yeah dude
you're scared man and I get it but you
lost your daughter
I hope the fear was worth it man because
you lost your daughter
and that's a conversation you'll have to
have one day with this little girl who's
gonna say Daddy what was so bad about me
that you didn't show up and you're gonna
have to say well I was really scared
right
yeah yeah that
and I play that scenario out in my head
all the time and uh but you've been
playing it for six years right five
years how old is this little girl
five five jeez man
like this is so F uh man I'm not gonna
keep saying that I just don't have the
psychology for it
um I
I don't know what keeps you from
knocking off work today and driving to
Alabama and saying Hey I want to have a
sit-down conversation with the other two
grown-ups in my child's life
um and I guess at this point you're
married so bringing your wife along too
and here's a
here's what I can't answer I can't
answer the psychological impact on this
little girl
other than to know it's gonna be she's
gonna have it rough either way
um
I she's going to at some point reach out
to you
um
ah man I'm just thinking about this in
real time dude
um
it wasn't going to be easy for any
anybody on yeah in in this situation
tell me about this step dad
from the the little I know about him
he's
a pretty awesome guy
um
I uh
he
he's involved in in their Church
um and has has brought
my daughter's mom and daughter into
um a community with faith
um
and he uh
takes
time
um for the longest time I worked nights
and he works nights also and it's just
really hard on her body and he would uh
first thing he would do when he would
get home is just spend hours playing
with uh
his our daughter and uh
he's I don't have a bad thing to say
about him
um is it shaming to you that he's been
more present in your daughter's life in
that way than you have
100 okay
I'm just gonna run through a couple of
ideas man but I'm telling you right now
I'm recommending things that I would
never do okay
is that cool okay
um
I can see a scenario where you drive to
Alabama and you meet him
for breakfast or lunch somewhere
and you get to know him
and you sign over parental rights to him
and ask permission to write letters the
idea that they're going to keep her from
knowing about you is false that will not
happen she'll figure it out and if they
lie to her
um it's no good
but if there's a way that in 15 years or
seven years or whenever they have this
conversation she's five so it should be
it should be now right
um
that there is a backlog of letters from
Dad talking about how much
he loves you
or loves her and
how much he supports this man raising
his daughter
um I could see that being one scenario I
can see another scenario where you
foreign
yeah we pack up everything and go to
Alabama probably what's going to happen
is she's going to take you to court and
you're gonna lose
maybe not but that would be my guess
or you'll get every other weekend and
then you're gonna be seven months into a
new State trying to find work and it's
going to be a mess
yeah either either way it's a mess
um and
I uh
what do you want to do
it depends on nope nope no what time of
day you ask me um what do you want to do
here's what I'm telling you I'm not
going to judge either way right now I've
already I've I've
you can hear my voice I beat you up
enough what do you want to do
I want it
to sign over my rights and have
her new dad
um so when where I walked away okay
sign over the parental rights then ma'am
okay
hard thing it is to do because I'll say
that out loud to to my wife or
by myself while I'm driving and then
I'll just break down and fall apart
feel like that's the wrong thing then
get in your car and move your family
today man
like you're just like you're wasting
year after year after year just driving
down the same road having the same
conversation with yourself and having
the same reaction do something man
because that little girl's getting older
every day
have you corrected this with your son
yes yeah uh yeah he uh
he has a very present Dad I'm not Bandit
from Bluey but I'm
I'm not either I want to be so bad dude
that dad's incredible dude I I tell you
what that's
that's the The Benchmark that I try to
hold myself to for uh my son it's
phenomenal so
um yeah
I worked a 31 hour shift yesterday and
uh still came home and spent spent four
hours
um playing airplane and wackawaka and
reading books good
um
in it so
I don't know man part
this is the single most conflicted I've
ever been on the show
I I knew it was going to be tough for
you I tried to phrase it in a way that
you were prepared um no I appreciate it
beforehand like every every ounce of my
being says go rescue that little girl
and every ounce of my being says you
cashed out five years ago dude it's time
to move on
but I know you can't move on from your
daughter
and so I'll say it this way there is no
decision you can make that's not going
to cause people hurt
there's no decision you can make that
you're going to feel great about when
it's over
and there's no decision you can make
that is not going to leave an ache
inside your little girl that she's gonna
have to manage for a long long long time
that ship has sailed
so now it's about making the best right
decision even though it's going to be
painful and even though it's going to be
hard
because it's going to be painful and
hard to drive to Alabama and say I
screwed up
this isn't the man I want to be and I
want to be present in my daughter's life
and you sir have been
an extraordinary man
I honor you
I can't give my daughter away
um but you have my full blessing on
being her her stepdad here
but I'm going to be living three miles
away and I want to see her every week
or you drive down there and you meet
with the three of them uh with or with
the two of them and you'll have a hard
conversation
and you sign over rights but let them
know I gotta write letters and you got
to read the letters to my daughter
because now y'all are all in this
playing a long game for her
psychological and physiological and
spiritual well-being
and that Daddy Gap is big
the stress that Mom was under for the
first two or three years of that little
girl's life
has altered her biochemistry and it's
going to take a long time to heal
so either way this is hard
and if you sent over parental rights it
wouldn't surprise me if your wife would
leave you
and so moving from Florida Tampa Bay one
of the most beautiful places on the
planet to Alabama I can only imagine how
hard that would be for everybody
um
I'm sorry I don't have a clean answer
for you dude
my gut tells me you you cashed out a
while ago
um you cashed out five years ago and the
guilt and the shame of standing in the
shadow of this other guy who stepped in
to help
um is what's keeping you up at night not
your little girl but your ego and if
that's the case Let It Go Let Her Go
live whatever positive life she can
under the loving arms of the sky
foreign
if you're ready to change your life Ctrl
alt delete and fix every just heal
everything
and you're willing to pack up a move
across the country and say I'm not
living another day without my daughter
in my life
um
before you jump up and do that you need
to go have conversations with the two of
them because they may be ready to sue
you and take you to court and they will
probably win
but I'd have that conversation all of
this is done in person
on your dime on your travel
all this is done in person and stop
having the same conversation in your
head over and over and over and over
trying to find a loophole out there is
no way out there's only through
and at the end of the day this whole
conversation is about the little girl
it's about the little girl